Noah, Abraham, King Solomon-- they all sacrificed animals, right? That's just the way they did it in the Old Testament. That's how you worshipped God. And the Old Testament is pretty unambiguous that this is God's very favorite way for people to worship. Exodus says that we're supposed to continue doing this "for generations to come."
诺亚、亚伯拉罕、所罗门王——他们都献祭过动物，对吧？在旧约时代，这就是他们的习俗，也是他们敬拜上帝的方式。而且旧约非常明确地指出，这是上帝最喜爱的敬拜方式。《出埃及记》中提到，我们应该“世世代代”继续这样做。
Deuteronomy warns us against worshipping in other ways, quote, "detestable ways that God hates. See that you do all I command you. Do not add to it or take away from it."
《申命记》警告我们不要以其他方式敬拜，引用原文：“上帝所憎恶的可憎之事。凡我所吩咐你的，都要谨守遵行。不可加添，也不可删减。”
So as a kid going to Hebrew school in suburban Baltimore, I never understood why we weren't doing this for God, how we got off the hook from animal sacrifice, the thing that he specifically said was the very best way to show our feelings for him. And it wasn't until this week that I finally learned the reason that we were off the hook. And the reason turns out to be astonishingly simple. Here's a scholar from Boston University named Jonathan Klawans, who is deeply over-qualified to answer this question.
所以作为一个在巴尔的摩郊区上希伯来学校的孩子，我一直不明白为什么我们不再为上帝这样做，我们是怎么摆脱动物献祭这一义务的——毕竟那是上帝亲口说过的向他表达情感的最佳方式。直到这周，我才终于了解到我们摆脱这一义务的原因。原因出奇地简单。这是波士顿大学的学者乔纳森·克拉万斯，他在这方面有着极为资深的学术背景。
The book of Deuteronomy actually also makes very clear that the only legitimate place for sacrifice is in the place where the Lord God will choose.
《申命记》其实也说得很清楚，唯一合法的献祭地点是耶和华上帝所选择的地方。
And the place that God chose was the temple in Jerusalem. When that was destroyed back in the year 70, it became basically illegal for Jews to sacrifice animals anywhere. Anyway, Jonathan Klawans says that there is a real bias against sacrifice today that began with people centuries ago.
上帝选择的地方是耶路撒冷的圣殿。当圣殿在公元70年被毁后，犹太人在任何地方献祭动物基本上都成了非法的。无论如何，乔纳森·克拉万斯说，今天人们对献祭存在真正的偏见，这种偏见始于几个世纪前。
None of these people were vegetarians. These weren't animal rights motivations. This was a notion that somehow prayer is better than sacrifice because it's more meaningful. It's more spiritual. In a way, I view sacrificers as a historical underdog.
这些人中没有一个是素食主义者，他们并非出于保护动物的动机。这源于一种观念，即祷告比献祭更好，因为它更有意义，也更属灵。在某种程度上，我把献祭者视为历史上的弱势群体。
In our conversation, by the way, he was careful to point out that he is not an advocate for animal sacrifice. Hold those emails. But he wrote a book that covers this material called Purity, Sacrifice, and the Temple. And he thinks that modern people have not bothered to think through what it would feel like to bring an animal to temple to kill it, to burn parts of it-- or all of it-- as a gift that you were personally giving to the creator of everything.
顺便提一下，他在谈话中特意指出，他并不主张动物献祭。别急着发邮件抗议。但他写了一本名为《纯洁、献祭与圣殿》的书，涵盖了这些内容。他认为现代人根本没费心去思考过那种感受：把一只动物带到圣殿宰杀，将其部分或全部烧掉，作为你个人献给万物创造主的礼物。
It's stuff. One is giving something. One of the points that's often emphasized, even in the biblical tradition-- and also in later rabbinic tradition-- about sacrifice is that a proper sacrifice is something that one owns. You can't go steal an animal and sacrifice it to God. And we also have to remember even if we think of animals as property, ancients-- one has to imagine the domesticated life of people, shepherds, living with their animals, who know their animals. A proper sacrifice has to be unblemished.
这是实物。献祭就是给予。即使在圣经传统——以及后来的拉比传统——中，关于献祭最常强调的一点是，正当的献祭必须是属于献祭者自己的。你不能偷一只动物来献给上帝。我们还要记住，即使我们把动物视为财产，古人——你得想象一下人们的驯养生活，牧羊人与他们的动物朝夕相处，非常了解它们。正当的献祭必须是毫无瑕疵的。
To have an unblemished goat, one has to really care for that goat, from the time that the goat is born, to ensure that that goat will not become blemished in some way.
要拥有一只无瑕疵的山羊，就必须从羊出生起就悉心照料，确保它不会出现任何瑕疵。
So you have a relationship with that goat. When you inspect it for blemishes-- which is Bible speak for any kind of nick, or bruise, or anything-- the goat looks you in the eye. And when you give this animal that you personally know to God, God isn't some abstract being. He is someone, someone who takes delight when you bring something to him, who you have this very literal interaction with. The Bible talks about the smell of the smoke reaching and summoning God.
所以你和那只羊之间是有感情的。当你检查它是否有瑕疵时——这是圣经用语，指任何伤口、淤青或类似痕迹——羊会盯着你的眼睛看。当你把这只你亲手照料的动物献给上帝时，上帝不再是一个抽象的存在。他是一个真实的对象，一个当你带给他东西时会感到喜悦的对象，一个和你有着非常真实互动关系的对象。圣经中提到烟雾的味道升腾并召唤着上帝。
So yes, there's something really powerful there. There's a ancient writer who writes in the Roman defense of sacrifices. And he says, worship without sacrifice is just words.
所以，是的，这里面确实有着非常强大的力量。有一位古代作家在为献祭进行辩护时写道：没有献祭的敬拜只是空话。
I love that phrase, because it totally turns us on our head. We moderns assume that prayer is better than sacrifice. We're so programmed to this. We think that words are better than deeds. Or we think that thoughts are better than actions. But talk is cheap.
我很喜欢这句话，因为它彻底颠覆了我们的认知。我们现代人认为祷告优于献祭。我们被这种观念彻底同化了。我们认为言语比行动更好，或者认为思想比行为更重要。但说起来容易做起来难。
Of course, what the animal gets out of this transaction-- the Bible doesn't say a lot about that. But understanding sacrifices, weighing the sacrifice that an animal makes for us, that raises some very basic questions.
当然，动物在这场交易中得到了什么——圣经对此并没有说太多。但理解献祭，权衡动物为我们做出的牺牲，引出了一些非常基本的问题。
What is sacrifice?
什么是牺牲？
Well, today on our program, animals and what they sacrifice for us. We have a story from Susan Orlean about household pets that are asked to get off the couch and do much more than my dog or yours ever does. And how I learned that everybody who I work with here at This American Life-- they have for years been very, very concerned with one animal. I really had no idea at all.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要谈谈动物以及它们为我们做出的牺牲。我们有苏珊·奥尔林关于家养宠物的故事，它们被要求离开沙发，去承担比我的狗或你的狗多得多的任务。我还了解到，我在这里的“美国生活”节目组的同事们，多年来一直非常非常关心一种动物。我之前完全不知道。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是“美国生活”节目，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Semper Fido. So our show today is about animal sacrifice. And of course, there are times when we ask animals to make the ultimate sacrifice. And in this act, I am not talking about the cows and chickens who die for burgers and fast food. I am talking about pets-- dogs, specifically. Susan Orlean tells the story.
第一幕，永远忠诚。所以我们今天的节目是关于动物献祭的。当然，有时我们会要求动物做出终极牺牲。在这一幕中，我说的不是那些为了汉堡和快餐而死的牛鸡。我说的是宠物——尤其是狗。苏珊·奥尔林讲述了这个故事。
Tommy wasn't a bad dog. He wasn't a mean dog, but he kept getting into trouble. Tommy was a German shepherd who belonged to the Snyder family in Allentown, Pennsylvania.
汤米不是一条坏狗，也不是一条恶狗，但他总是惹麻烦。汤米是一条属于宾夕法尼亚州阿伦敦斯奈德一家的德国牧羊犬。
Tommy's trouble was impulse control. He refused to stay in the yard. He chased ducks in the city park. And on at least one occasion, the authorities had to round him up. Gina Snyder was in high school at the time.
汤米的问题是冲动控制。他拒绝呆在院子里，在城市公园追逐鸭子。至少有一次，当局不得不把他抓起来。吉娜·斯奈德当时还在上高中。
The problem with Tommy was that I thought he woke up, and he said, oh, for the open road. He was ready to take off. Run anywhere, that was his nature. Even though he was fastened to the doghouse, if he wanted to go, he would go. He would take the doghouse with him and run out the front yard and down the street--
汤米的问题是，我觉得他醒来时就像在说，哦，广阔的世界在等着我。他随时准备冲出去。到处跑就是他的天性。即使把他拴在狗屋上，只要他想走，他就会走。他会拖着狗屋冲出前院，跑下街道——
Dragging the house.
拖着房子。
Dragging the house behind him.
拖着房子在后面。
This was in the early 1940s, before there were dog whisperers and dog therapists and beef-flavored Prozac. The Snyders really liked Tommy, but they just didn't know what to do with him. But then World War II started and provided a solution.
那是20世纪40年代初，那时候还没有所谓的“狗语者”、“狗治疗师”或牛肉味的百忧解。斯奈德一家真的很喜欢汤米，但就是不知道该拿他怎么办。后来第二次世界大战爆发了，提供了一个解决方案。
New recruits, a small detachment of the 125,000 dogs ordered by the quartermaster general for rigorous training in connection with MP sentry work the world over. They're using purebred Dobermans, shepherds, Dalmatians, setters, collies, Airedales, even poodles and Great Danes. And each dog is carefully selected by experienced trainers for boldness and aggressiveness as watch dogs, fierce enough and tough enough to hold a man at bay until human help arrives.
新兵们，一小支由军需官将军下令征召的12.5万只军犬中的一队，它们要在世界各地进行与宪兵哨所工作相关的严格训练。他们使用的是纯种杜宾犬、牧羊犬、达尔马提亚犬、雪达犬、柯利犬、艾尔谷梗，甚至还有贵宾犬和大丹犬。每只狗都经过经验丰富的训练师精心挑选，要求具备作为看门狗的胆识和攻击性，足够凶猛、足够强壮，能够将人困住直到人类援军到达。
There are lots of dogs in the US military these days. That hasn't always been the case. The US didn't have a canine corps in World War I, even though every other country in the war did. And at the time of the attack on Pearl Harbor, the only American military dogs were a few dozen huskies in Alaska.
如今美国军队里有很多狗，但情况并非一贯如此。第一次世界大战时美国并没有军犬队，尽管战争中的每个其他国家都有。在珍珠港袭击发生时，美国军队里仅有的军犬是阿拉斯加的几十只哈士奇。
There were, though, a lot of people who believed we were missing out on an opportunity. After all, dogs could do certain things, like sniffing for land mines, that human soldiers couldn't. And they could handle jobs like guard duty on their own and free up troops for more demanding roles.
不过，当时很多人认为我们错过了一个机会。毕竟，狗能做一些人类士兵无法做到的事情，比如嗅探地雷。它们还能独自承担守卫任务，从而解放人力去执行更艰巨的任务。
The biggest advocate of dogs in the military was a very determined New York socialite named Alene Erlanger. Between lunches with her friend Eleanor Roosevelt, caring for her aviary of 500 rare songbirds, and operating the preeminent poodle kennel in the country, Erlanger helped found an organization called Dogs for Defense to promote the cause.
军队中狗的最大倡导者是一位非常有决心的纽约名流，名叫艾琳·厄兰格。在与她的好友埃莉诺·罗斯福共进午餐、照料她那拥有500只珍稀鸣禽的鸟舍，以及经营全国最出色的贵宾犬犬舍之余，厄兰格参与创办了一个名为“国防之犬”的组织，以推动这一事业。
She managed, finally, to persuade Quartermaster Edmund Gregory to try out a few hundred dogs to guard ammunition plants and depots. It was a success-- in fact, such a success that Gregory wanted 125,000 more dogs as soon as possible to serve beside American troops.
她最终设法说服了军需官埃德蒙·格雷戈里，让他试用几百只狗来守卫弹药厂和仓库。这非常成功——事实上太成功了，以至于格雷戈里尽快需要另外12.5万只狗来与美军并肩作战。
Each sentry dog must immediately learn not to get excited by the presence of another dog. The untrained [INAUDIBLE] dog's greatest failing, and so they're trained to walk through a group of dogs, paying attention only to the soldier trainer.
每只哨犬必须立即学会不被其他狗的存在所干扰。这是未经训练的狗最大的弱点，所以它们被训练成穿过一群狗时，只关注自己的士兵训练员。
The problem was finding 125,000 dogs on short notice. The solution was something never done before or since in this country. The Army asked Americans to loan their pets to the war effort, to sign them up as soldiers. Using Rin Tin Tin, the movie-star dog, as its mascot, Dogs for Defense began running ads and news features recruiting dogs for the Army. And amazingly enough, tens of thousands of people from all over the country responded.
问题在于要在短时间内找到12.5万只狗。解决方案是这个国家前所未有的。陆军请求美国人把他们的宠物借给战争事业，为它们报名参军。以电影明星狗“丁丁历险记”中的丁丁为吉祥物，“国防之犬”开始投放广告和新闻专题，为陆军招募狗。令人惊讶的是，全国成千上万的人做出了响应。
Of course, this was a time when people did just about anything they could to support the war effort, collecting scrap metal, rolling bandages, growing victory gardens. And now the War Department received thousands of letters from eager volunteers-- that is, people eagerly volunteering their dogs to volunteer, like this one. "We want to kill all of the Japs we can. We are glad to give Laddie away if he will help."
当然，那是人们尽其所能支持战争的时代，收集废金属、卷绷带、种植胜利花园。现在，战争部收到了成千上万封热情的志愿者来信——也就是那些急切地想志愿捐出自家狗的人，比如这封：“我们想尽可能多地杀掉日本人。如果拉迪能帮忙，我们很高兴把他送走。”
Or this one, from Bogalusa, Louisiana. "I went to the picture show last night, and on a newsreel reel or something, I saw where they are training dogs to help our soldiers on guard duty. Now, I have a pretty dog. He is a very smart dog. He was my brother's dog, but when he joined the Navy, he gave him to me. Now, if you all can use him and promise to feed him well, you can have him, for I know if he could talk, he would say that he wants to help our country. Yours truly, Earl Buck Boyd."
或者这封来自路易斯安那州博加卢萨的信：“我昨晚去看电影，在新闻短片中看到他们正在训练狗来帮助士兵执勤。现在，我有一条很漂亮的狗。他非常聪明。他是我兄弟的狗，但他参军入伍后就把狗留给了我。如果你们能用得着他，并且保证把他喂好，你们就可以把他带走，因为我知道如果他会说话，他一定会说他想为我们的国家出力。你忠实的，厄尔·巴克·博伊德。”
Here's one last one, from a woman in Towson, Maryland, offering her nine-month-old pup. "I love him because I know he will make a fine dog. But I also love my son, and I gave him up for war work. And I will give my dog also if he can help in this war. It is not much I can do, but if you can use him, send for him any time you want him. But when the war is over and he is still alive, return him back to me."
这是最后一封，来自马里兰州陶森的一位妇女，她捐出了自己九个月大的小狗。“我爱他，因为我知道他会成为一条好狗。但我也爱我的儿子，我把他送去打仗了。如果我的狗能在这场战争中有所帮助，我也会把他捐出来。我能做的不多，但如果你们用得着他，随时来接他。但当战争结束，如果他还活着，请把他还给我。”
As for Gina and her German shepherd, Tommy, Gina's father liked what he had heard about Dogs for Defense.
至于吉娜和她的德国牧羊犬汤米，吉娜的父亲很喜欢他听到的关于“国防之犬”的消息。
At any rate, someone came out to look at Tommy. And they said, yes, they would take him. And as I think back on it, it's sort of like if you have a teenager who's just difficult, having a lot of trouble, you can't really get him to be going the right way, and you think, oh, let's send him to military school. That'll probably straighten him out, get education and organization and so on. And this is sort of a little bit the way I think that Tommy went to the K-9 Corps, that they would train him--
无论如何，有人来看了汤米，他们说，是的，他们会收下他。如今回想起来，这有点像如果你家有个处处作对、惹麻烦的青少年，你没法让他走正路，于是你心想，送他去军校吧。那可能会让他改邪归正，让他接受教育和纪律之类的。我就是这样想汤米去K-9部队的，他们会训练他——
Shape him up.
让他振作起来。
The training's all important, and stress is laid on perfect and immediate obedience, learning to sense and discover the presence of suspicious persons out of sight or earshot of their MP master, to attack when ordered, to grab a trigger arm if there's a gun. Go get him, King. Get that trigger arm. Hold tight.
训练至关重要，重点在于完美和即时的服从，学习如何发现处于视野或听力范围之外的可疑人员，接到命令后进行攻击，如果对方有枪就抓住扣扳机的手臂。去抓住他，金。抓住那条手臂。咬紧。
At first, the Army and Marine Corps accepted just about any healthy dog that was at least 18 inches high at the shoulder. Over time, though, it became clear that not every dog was Army-ready. Great Danes were too big for combat. Hunting breeds were too easily distracted. And Dalmatians were too easy for the enemy to spot, even after the Army dyed them brown, since the dye came off in the rain. So the Army politely refused any dogs other than German shepherds, Belgian sheepdogs, Dobermans, collies, huskies, malamutes, and mutts that were mostly one of those breeds.
起初，陆军和海军陆战队接受任何肩高至少18英寸的健康犬。但随着时间的推移，情况变得明朗起来，并不是每只狗都准备好参军了。大丹犬在战斗中太大了。猎犬品种太容易分心。达尔马提亚犬太容易被敌人发现，即使陆军把它们染成棕色，染料也会在雨中褪去。所以陆军婉拒了除了德国牧羊犬、比利时牧羊犬、杜宾犬、柯利犬、哈士奇、阿拉斯加雪橇犬以及大部分是这些品种的杂交犬之外的所有狗。
There were an estimated 13 million dogs in the US at that time. America was undergoing the great migration off of farms and into cities. And people had less space than ever. And yet the number of dogs was exploding.
据估计，当时美国有1300万只狗。美国正在经历从农场到城市的大规模迁徙，人们的居住空间比以往任何时候都小，但狗的数量却在激增。
The thing is, we were keeping dogs for different reasons than in the past. Instead of being workers on farms and ranches, now dogs were just kept to be our companions. They were emotional allies.
问题在于，我们饲养狗的原因与过去不同了。它们不再是农场和牧场上的工作犬，现在养狗只是为了陪伴。它们成了情感上的盟友。
Now dogs lived among us, inside our houses rather than out in the yard, and treated as family members rather than livestock. Sending them off to war wasn't exactly the same as sending off a son or brother, but it was a lot more intimate than donating scrap metal or buying a war bond.
如今狗生活在我们中间，住在屋里而不是院子里，被当作家庭成员而不是牲畜来对待。把它们送去打仗并不完全等同于送走儿子或兄弟，但这比捐赠废金属或购买战争债券要亲密得多。
Each enlisted dog was issued a record book in which trainers detailed the animal's progress with comments like "Rollo is a high-spirited dog. He was very successful and did his job excellent." And "War Dog Mitzi has been on 25 combat patrols." Or "Dog caught cold while at sea, feverish." Or "Dog found to be out of her head. Trainers were unable to work with her."
每只入伍的狗都会发一个记录本，训练员会在上面详细记录动物的进步，评价包括“罗洛是一只精神抖擞的狗，他非常成功，工作表现出色。”或者“军犬米茨已经执行了25次战斗巡逻。”或者“狗在海上感冒了，发烧。”或者“狗精神失常，训练员无法与它配合。”
Just as people wanted to know how their family and friends in the Army were getting along, they wanted to know how their dogs were doing. They sent them Christmas cards and birthday cards, and wrote to the Army asking after Butch and Chips and Peppy and Smokey. At first, the Army tried to respond to all these inquiries. But as the mail piled up, they resorted to sending out a form letter, saying that in the interest of military secrecy, no further information about the dogs could be provided.
就像人们想知道他们在军队里的家人和朋友过得怎么样一样，他们也想知道自己的狗过得怎么样。他们给狗寄圣诞卡和生日卡，写信给军方询问布奇、奇普斯、佩皮和斯莫基的情况。起初，军方试图回复所有这些询问。但随着信件堆积如山，他们只好发送格式信，称出于军事保密的考虑，无法提供关于这些狗的进一步信息。
Not everyone was satisfied with that answer. One couple, a Mr. and Mrs. Powell, complained to their congressman when they didn't get any news about their dog Lucky. The congressman contacted the quartermaster, who wrote back saying, "The desire for such information is but a natural one and well understood by this office. However, due to the large number of dogs constantly being received for training, it is physically impossible to furnish the desired information to each individual donor without incurring the expense of employing a large clerical force. It is the desire of this office to assure Mr. and Mrs. Powell that their dog is receiving the best of care and attention and has been given a position in the War Dog program where he will do the most good."
并不是每个人都对这个回答感到满意。一对名叫鲍威尔的夫妇在没收到关于他们狗“幸运”的消息时，向他们的国会议员进行了投诉。国会议员联系了军需官，军需官回复说：“对此类信息的渴望是自然的，本办公室非常理解。然而，由于收到的待训犬只数量庞大，若要在不雇佣大量文职人员增加费用的情况下为每位捐赠者提供信息，物理上是不可能的。本办公室希望向鲍威尔夫妇保证，他们的狗正在得到最好的照料，并在军犬计划中担任最合适的位置。”
All that most people knew was that their pets were helping win the war. In the National Archives, there's footage of canine training that the military didn't make public until after the war. It shows dogs crawling through tunnels, running telephone wires across mock battlefields, and delivering ammunition and carrier pigeons to soldiers in trenches. In another scene, the dogs practice attacking enemy soldiers played by Japanese-American volunteers.
大多数人只知道他们的宠物正在帮助赢得战争。在国家档案馆，有一些军方直到战后才公开的犬类训练镜头。镜头显示狗在隧道中爬行，在模拟战场上铺设电话线，为战壕里的士兵运送弹药和信鸽。在另一个场景中，狗练习攻击由日裔美国志愿者扮演的敌军士兵。
There was one job in the K-9 Corps that I didn't know about until recently, something the Army called Bunker Dogs. In the National Archives, I found pictures of three of them, a German shepherd, a Doberman, and a collie, each wearing an elaborate canvas saddlebag. The next photograph showed the contents of the saddlebag-- 40 pounds of explosives, a time-delay fuse, and a detonator-- with the caption "Bunker dog loaded for operation with equipment shown." These dogs were training to be suicide bombers. In the pictures, they look eager and happy, their ears and tails at alert, the way dogs so often do.
K-9部队里有一个职位我直到最近才知道，陆军称之为“碉堡犬”。在国家档案馆，我找到了三只狗的照片，一只德国牧羊犬、一只杜宾犬和一只柯利犬，每只都背着一个复杂的帆布马鞍袋。下一张照片显示了马鞍袋里的东西——40磅的炸药、延时引信和雷管——标题是“已装载碉堡作业装备的碉堡犬”。这些狗当时正在接受自杀式炸弹训练。在照片中，它们看起来热切而快乐，耳朵和尾巴竖起，就像狗常有的那样。
Did you ever try to picture where he was or think about his circumstances once he had enlisted?
你有没有试着想象过他在哪里，或者在他入伍后思考过他的处境？
Well, I think maybe only in the sense that I might have thought about my high-school friends who had gone into the Army.
嗯，我想也许只有在我想到那些参军的高中朋友时，我才会那样想。
Again, Gina Snyder.
又是吉娜·斯奈德。
I'm probably brainwashed by some kind of movies or something, because I could see him walking with a soldier and scouting patrol, or looking for Germans, probably very unrealistic, kind of daydreamed-- but bravely doing a service out on the battlefield.
我可能被电影之类的东西洗脑了，因为我能想象他跟着一名士兵在巡逻队里探路，或者寻找德国人，这可能非常不现实，但我就是那样白日做梦——想象他在战场上勇敢地执行任务。
When you donated your pet to the military, you had to sign a form saying you understood that the training and experience of combat might change your dog's personality permanently and that the government wasn't liable if your dog came home a killer. This could have had a chilling effect, so the Army publicized the fact that every dog would be deprogrammed before it was discharged, with lots of petting and cuddling. Newspapers ran encouraging stories about demobilized dogs and their successful return to their families, along with photos of the dogs at home, with captions like "Here's Spike in civilian life" and "Goofy the Warrior Dog comes home," and letters from families describing happy reunions.
当你把宠物捐给军方时，你必须签署一份表格，声明你了解战斗的训练和经历可能会永久改变你狗的性格，如果你的狗回家后变成了一个杀手，政府概不负责。这可能会产生寒蝉效应，所以陆军宣传说，每只狗在退役前都会通过大量的爱抚和拥抱进行心理修复。报纸刊登了关于复员军犬成功回到家人身边的励志故事，并配上它们在家里的照片，标题如“这是平民生活中的斯派克”和“英雄狗古菲回家了”，以及家庭描述重聚幸福时刻的信件。
Even Lassie got in on the effort. In 1946, the collie starred along with Elizabeth Taylor in The Courage of Lassie, a film about a gentle collie named Bill with PTSD.
连莱西都参与了这项工作。1946年，这只柯利犬与伊丽莎白·泰勒主演了《莱西的勇气》，这是一部关于一只名叫比尔、患有创伤后应激障碍的温顺柯利犬的电影。
A sudden cruel twist of fate took Bill away from Kathie, and he found himself in a different world among strange people who fought and killed. Mutely and heroically, he struggled against this man-made inferno. Wounded and spirit shattered, Bill broke away and returned to the land he once knew. But he came back a killer. He heard the call of the wild and answered.
突如其来的残酷命运让比尔离开了凯西，他发现自己身处一个充满陌生人的世界，那里充满了战斗和杀戮。他默默地、英勇地与这人间地狱作斗争。受伤且精神崩溃的比尔逃了出来，回到了他曾经熟悉的土地。但他回来时已经变成了一个杀手。他听到了野性的呼唤并做出了回应。
[DOG GROWLING]
[狗的低吼声]
Of course, this was war, and some of the dogs never came home. Here's Marine Private First Class Mason Wachtsletter writing to the owners of a dog named Tubby. "Tubby was in the front lines 23 days and had been on about 15 patrols. The second night in, he ran four Japs into a cave. And when they thought he was coming after them, they blew their heads off with hand grenades.
当然，这是战争，有些狗没能回家。这是海军陆战队一等兵梅森·瓦奇莱特写给一只名叫塔比的狗的主人的信。“塔比在前线待了23天，执行了大约15次巡逻。在进入的第二天晚上，他把四个日本人赶进了一个山洞。当他们以为他在追他们时，他们用手榴弹炸死了自己。
Now I have to tell you the worst. Tubby was shot and killed the night of August 31. He behaved like a true Marine at all times and didn't even whimper when he died. We've buried him in the Marine Cemetery along with the other real heroes of this campaign. And if it is at all possible, I'll send you a picture of his grave. He has a cross with his name and rank. He's a corporal."
现在我必须告诉你最糟糕的消息。塔比在8月31日晚上被射杀。他始终表现得像一个真正的海军陆战队员，死时甚至没有呜咽。我们把他和这场战役中其他真正的英雄一起埋在了海军陆战队公墓。如果可能的话，我一定会寄给你一张他墓地的照片。他有一个十字架，上面刻着他的名字和军衔。他是一名下士。”
The first news the Snyders got about Tommy came some months after he had joined the Army.
斯奈德一家关于汤米的第一个消息是在他参军几个月后收到的。
It didn't say killed in action. I think that would have impressed itself on my mind. It said, killed something, and I don't know what-- "killed in service," or what it was. I don't know what he did, was it a scout dog, a patrol dog. I have no idea. But all I remember is standing by the window crying, of course.
信上没有写“阵亡”。我想如果写了，我肯定会记得。上面写着，killed（杀）后面接了什么，我不记得了——可能是“因公殉职”之类的。我不知道他做了什么，是侦察犬还是巡逻犬。我完全不知道。但我只记得当时站在窗边哭泣，当然。
But as I look back on it-- and I think even at that time-- I thought, I hope he was brave. It was somebody in your family who had served and had died in the service. And that was it.
但如今回想起来——我想当时也是——我心想，我希望他很勇敢。那是你家庭中的一员，在服役期间牺牲了。事情就是这样。
Oh, that's so sad, terrible.
哦，太令人难过了，太可怕了。
Well, Susan, I have to tell you, it is sad. It was sad then. It's sad now. But I have to be honest and tell you that underneath it all, I'm still very proud of him. It's silly, but I take pride in the fact that he performed a service.
嗯，苏珊，我必须告诉你，这确实很悲伤。当时很悲伤，现在也很悲伤。但我必须诚实地告诉你，在这一切之下，我仍然为他感到非常自豪。这很傻，但我为他执行了一项任务而感到自豪。
And I don't know how useful. Maybe he saved somebody. I just don't know. I don't know what.
我不知道有多大的用处。也许他救了某人，我只是不知道。不知道具体是什么。
Or maybe he was totally irresponsible and got killed that way. I don't know. But I am proud of him, just as I would have been if it had been a member of my family. His life was worth something.
或者也许他完全不负责任，就那样死掉了。我不知道。但我为他感到自豪，就像如果这是我家的一员一样。他的生命是有价值的。
Dogs for Defense disbanded in 1945, but that wasn't the end of dogs in the military. It's just that borrowing people's pets was much more complicated than anyone had imagined. All those letters from anxious owners, all that petting and cuddling required to get the dogs reprogrammed as civilians. The Army decided it would be easier to buy dogs outright or accept donated dogs only if the owners agreed to give them away for good.
“国防之犬”组织于1945年解散，但军犬并没有因此终结。只是借用人们的宠物比任何人想象的要复杂得多。所有来自焦虑主人的信件，所有为了让狗修复心理而需要的爱抚和拥抱。陆军决定，干脆直接购买狗，或者只在主人同意永远捐赠的情况下接受捐赠会更容易。
From that point forward, the dogs in the Army became property of the Army. And they were then treated like property, just like a gun or a hand grenade that had been purchased from a military supplier. There were thousands of dogs used in Korea and Vietnam. And almost none of them came back.
从那以后，陆军中的狗就成了陆军的财产。它们被当作财产对待，就像从军火商那里购买的枪支或手榴弹一样。在朝鲜战争和越南战争中使用了数千只狗，几乎没有一只回来。
It wasn't till the year 2000, when Congress passed a law making it possible, that the dogs' handlers, or police departments, or just dog lovers were allowed to adopt them after the war. Before that, when the war ended, the dogs were left behind. Or in many cases, over the protests of their handlers, they were euthanized.
直到2000年，国会通过了一项法律，允许它们的训练员、警察部门或普通的爱狗人士在战后领养它们。在那之前，战争结束后，狗要么被遗弃，要么在许多情况下，违背了它们训练员的抗议，被实施了安乐死。
Without knowing what the war was for, the dogs had done what they'd been asked to do. Because that's the nature of the bond we have with dogs. We take care of them and ask them to trust us, and they do.
狗并不知道战争是为了什么，但它们完成了它们被要求做的事情。因为这就是我们与狗之间联系的本质。我们照顾它们，要求它们信任我们，而它们做到了。
Susan Orlean-- she's a staff writer at The New Yorker . An account of the World War II Dogs for Defense program is part of her book Rin Tin Tin, the Life and the Legend, which is out in paperback. Incredible photos of dogs in World War II from the National Archives, including dogs in suicide vests, are at our website, thisamericanlife.org. Coming up, Hop Along Catastrophe. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
苏珊·奥尔林——她是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人。她关于二战“国防之犬”计划的记述是她书《丁丁：生平与传奇》的一部分，该书已有平装本。国家档案馆中关于二战中军犬（包括身穿自杀式炸弹背心的狗）的不可思议的照片，请访问我们的网站thisamericanlife.org。接下来是“跳跃的灾难”。从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司播出，稍后继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, animal sacrifice, stories about what other creatures give up for us. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Rabbit, Run. No, Really, Run! This is a true story, this story, of crime and murder, from Camas Davis.
这是“美国生活”。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是关于动物献祭，关于其他生物为我们放弃了什么。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“兔子，跑吧。不，真的，跑吧！”这是一个关于犯罪和谋杀的真实故事，来自卡马斯·戴维斯。
Sometime between 1:30 and 8:00 AM on January 8, 2012, five adults, including a nursing mother and 13 juveniles, vanished from their cages in a Portland backyard. 10 one-day-old babies were left behind and subsequently died. We're talking rabbits here, compact, cute, furry, doe-eyed, white, brown, and black little hopping animals that were being bred and raised for meat, meat that would feed the rabbits' owners and a few of their friends.
在2012年1月8日凌晨1点30分到8点之间的某个时间，五只成年兔（包括一只哺乳期的母兔）和13只幼兔从波特兰的一个后院笼子里消失了。10只刚出生一天的幼兔被丢弃，随后死亡。我们这里说的是兔子，那种紧凑、可爱、毛茸茸、大眼睛、白色、棕色和黑色的小跳跃动物，它们是为了肉食而被饲养和繁育的，这些肉将供养兔子的主人和他们的一些朋友食用。
These are the facts. I'm a journalist by trade, but to feign impartiality in this story from this point on will be nearly impossible, because I also own and operate a company that teaches people how to slaughter and butcher whole animals for personal consumption. As it so happens, on the morning of January 8, I was scheduled to co-teach a class on how to raise and slaughter rabbits for meat. The 11 rabbits we used for that class also came from the backyard of the vanished rabbits. However, they'd been transported to the location of the class the night before.
这些就是事实。我是职业记者，但要在这里保持中立几乎是不可能的，因为我也拥有并经营一家公司，教人们如何为个人消费宰杀和处理全禽。巧合的是，在1月8日那天早上，我原定联合授课一门关于如何饲养和宰杀兔子作为肉食的课程。我们在那堂课上使用的11只兔子也来自消失兔子的那个后院。然而，它们在前一天晚上就被运到了上课地点。
These 11 rabbits did not vanish in the same way their brethren did. They did, however, die. Here's how they died.
这11只兔子并没有像它们的同类那样消失。但它们确实死了。以下是它们死亡的方式。
Within the span of one second, we broke their necks. Within the span of another second, their eyes closed, their nervous systems shut down, their brains went dark. That was it. They were alive one minute, gone the next, vanished.
在一秒钟内，我们折断了它们的脖子。在接下来的那一秒，它们的眼睛闭上了，神经系统关闭了，大脑陷入了黑暗。就这样。它们上一分钟还活着，下一分钟就没了，消失了。
Some people call this slaughter. Some people call it dispatching. Some people call it killing. Some call it murder.
有些人称之为屠宰，有些人称之为处决，有些人称之为杀戮，有些人称之为谋杀。
Some call it torture. Some call it vulgar. Some call it food.
有些人称之为折磨，有些人称之为庸俗，有些人称之为食物。
Here is how the 10 day-old baby rabbits without the warmth or sustenance of their nursing mothers died. They suffered from hypothermia, they slowly starved to death, or they did both. Some held on for a while with the help of a man-made nest of blankets and attempts to bottle-feed. Some didn't.
这就是那10只没有母兔温暖和哺乳的刚出生幼兔死亡的方式。它们死于失温，慢慢饿死，或者两者皆有。有些人在人造毛毯窝的帮助下和人工喂奶的尝试下坚持了一会儿。有些没有。
By the end of the day of January 8, within the span of 6 to 12 hours, all 10 of them had died, vanished. Some people call this slaughter. Some call it killing. Some call it suffering.
到1月8日结束时，在6到12小时内，它们全部死亡，消失了。有些人称之为屠宰，有些人称之为杀戮，有些人称之为痛苦。
Some call it justice. Some call it saving sentient beings from the evil hands of a murderer. It all depends, of course, on who you ask.
有些人称之为正义，有些人称之为从谋杀者的邪恶手中拯救有知觉的生物。当然，这完全取决于你问的是谁。
My co-instructor for the class on January 8 was also the co-owner of the vanished rabbits. His name is Levi. Together with his friend Chris, Levi breeds and raises a small number of rabbits to feed their friends and families. During their lives, the bunnies live in cages that are larger than the Humane Society says they need to be, with plenty of room to move around and hop.
我1月8日那节课的共同导师也是那些消失兔子的共同拥有者。他的名字叫列维。他和他的朋友克里斯一起饲养少量的兔子来供应给朋友和家人。在它们一生中，这些兔子生活在比人道协会要求的更大、有足够空间活动和跳跃的笼子里。
On the morning of January 8, when Chris discovered 10 day-old babies struggling to stay alive, he tended to the most important detail-- keeping those babies alive and trying to ease their suffering. He knew of a local rabbit advocacy group that usually had nursing mothers. In the course of talking to them, Chris and the advocates realized that his stolen bunnies had been anonymously donated to the organization. The organization had immediately fostered the rabbits out to various homes.
1月8日早上，当克里斯发现10只刚出生的幼兔在死亡边缘挣扎时，他处理了最紧迫的细节——保持这些幼兔的生命并试图减轻它们的痛苦。他知道当地有一个通常有哺乳期母兔的兔子权益组织。在与他们交谈的过程中，克里斯和这些权益倡导者意识到，他的被盗兔子被匿名捐赠给了该组织。该组织立即将这些兔子寄养到了不同的家庭。
Then, an unexpected turn. When the organization realized these rabbits were headed for the dinner table, they announced they did not want to give the rabbits back. They got their animal-rights lawyer involved. He told Levi and Chris that the foster parents of these rabbits had grown attached to their new pets.
然后，出现了意想不到的转折。当该组织意识到这些兔子最终会被摆上餐桌时，他们宣布不想归还这些兔子。他们找来了他们的动物权益律师。律师告诉列维和克里斯，这些兔子的寄养家庭已经对这些新宠物产生了感情。
The organization offered $1,500 in total for all of the fostered rabbits. That's $83 a rabbit. Levi and Chris typically charge between $15 and $20 for a live rabbit, which reimburses them for the cost of raising them.
该组织总共为所有寄养的兔子提供了1500美元。相当于每只兔子83美元。列维和克里斯通常每只活兔收费15到20美元，这只是补偿了他们的饲养成本。
Levi and Chris told them, these rabbits were stolen. We would like for you to return them. If you would then like to knock on our door and buy them from us at cost, we would be happy to see you.
列维和克里斯告诉他们，这些兔子是偷来的。我们希望你们归还。如果你想敲开我们的门并以成本价从我们这里购买，我们很乐意接待你们。
Chris and Levi waited to hear back. The advocates waited for them to change their minds. It was a standoff. The lawyer acted as go-between.
克里斯和列维等待着回复。权益倡导者们则等待着他们改变主意。这成了僵局。律师在中间传话。
In 2009, after 10 years of working as a magazine editor in New York and then Portland, I was laid off for the first time in my life. Like so many victims of the recession, I pouted for a while and then decided to completely reinvent myself, this time as a butcher. I asked chefs and butchers if they'd be willing to teach me. None had the time or the interest.
2009年，在纽约和波特兰做了10年杂志编辑后，我人生中第一次被裁员。像许多经济衰退的受害者一样，我难过了很久，然后决定彻底重塑自己，这一次是成为一名屠夫。我问厨师和屠夫他们是否愿意教我。没人有时间或兴趣。
Through a friend of a friend, I found the Chapolards, a French family of four brothers who, with two of their wives, own and operate a farm in southwestern France where they handle every aspect of getting pork to dinner tables. I bought a plane ticket. I spoke no French. The Chapolards spoke little English. They handed me knives and pointed to pork legs and bellies and heads and shoulders and trusted I would find my way.
通过一个朋友的朋友，我找到了查波拉德一家，这是一个由四兄弟组成的法国农家，他们和两位妻子一起在法国西南部经营一个农场，处理把猪肉送上餐桌的每一个环节。我买了一张飞机票。我不会说法语。查波拉德一家几乎不会说英语。他们递给我刀，指向猪腿、猪腩、猪头和猪肩，相信我会找到路。
I returned to Oregon wanting to learn more. I told all those chefs and butchers who wouldn't teach me before that I'd find students to pay them to teach the art of butchery. The Portland Meat Collective was born. I had no idea that classes would sell out.
我回到俄勒冈州，想学习更多。我告诉那些之前不愿教我的厨师和屠夫，我会找到愿意付钱给他们学习屠宰艺术的学生。波特兰肉类集体就此诞生。我没想到课程会售罄。
The basic idea behind the Portland Meat Collective was this. I wanted omnivores, carnivores, pescetarians, fruititarians, vegetarians, breathetarians, and vegans alike to have the chance to truly engage with their food, with one another, and then decide where they stood on the meat-no-meat spectrum. Some students simply want to learn to raise animals. Some want to preserve meat at home. Others show up to learn how to butcher whole animals. And a few show up to see if they can stomach killing an animal.
波特兰肉类集体的基本理念是这样的：我希望杂食者、肉食者、鱼类素食者、果食者、素食主义者、呼吸食者和纯素食主义者都有机会真正与他们的食物接触，互相交流，然后决定他们在肉食与非肉食光谱上的立场。有些学生只是想学习饲养动物。有些人想在家制作腊肉。另一些人来学习如何处理全禽。还有一些人来这里看看自己是否有勇气去杀一只动物。
Media often question whether the Portland Meat Collective is just a bunch of privileged hipsters worshipping at the feet of the bacon gods. I usually tell them this. I am not obsessed with bacon.
媒体经常质疑波特兰肉类集体是否只是一群拜倒在培根之神脚下的特权文青。我通常这样回答他们：我并不沉迷于培根。
I do not growl and flex my muscles after breaking down a whole pig. I do not have a tattoo of a pig head on my bicep, nor do I have a boning knife tattooed on my calf. I abhor the term "meat head." and for the most part, so do my students.
我在分解整头猪后不会咆哮和展示肌肉。我的肱二头肌上没有猪头的纹身，我的小腿上也没有剔骨刀的纹身。我厌恶“肉头”这个词，我的大多数学生也一样。
I tell them that after taking my classes, many report that they eat less meat. My students also tell me that they can't bring themselves to buy most of the meat they see in grocery stores anymore. I tell them that that's what happened to me, too. I tell them I was raised as a hunter and fisher, that my dad handed me a fish whacker when I was 7 and told me to hit the fish in the head with it after I hooked it and slowly reeled it into the boat, to ease its suffering, he said.
我告诉他们，上完我的课后，许多人报告说他们吃肉更少了。我的学生还告诉我说，他们再也无法忍受购买在杂货店看到的绝大多数肉了。我告诉他们，这也是发生在我身上的事。我告诉他们我从小是猎人和渔夫，我父亲在我7岁时递给我一根鱼棒，让我把钩住并慢慢拉到船边的鱼打死，他说这是为了减轻它的痛苦。
I tell them I turned vegetarian for 10 years, and then ate meat without thinking about why or from whence it came for another 10 years. The Portland Meat Collective is where I stand now, I say. It feels honest and blatant, respectful and messy. I tell them that there is something about all of this that makes some people really, really angry.
我告诉他们，我做了10年的素食主义者，然后又盲目地吃了10年的肉，不考虑原因或来源。我说，波特兰肉类集体就是我现在的立场。它感觉诚实、直接、尊重且混乱。我告诉他们，这一切中有些东西让一些人感到非常非常愤怒。
When the rabbits vanished, Levi, Chris, and I chose to publicize it, to try and get the rabbits back and in hopes of finding the person or people who took the rabbits. Stories appeared in local and national newspapers. Sometimes I woke up to emails like this. "Things you should do today. Number one, get cancer. Number two, rot slowly and painfully."
当兔子消失时，列维、克里斯和我决定公开此事，试图找回兔子，并希望能找到拿走兔子的人。当地和全国性的报纸都登了故事。有时我醒来会看到这样的邮件：“你今天应该做的事。第一，得癌症。第二，慢慢地、痛苦地腐烂。”
Others imagined my demise in more inventive ways. "You are chicken [BLEEP]. I'd love to see you in a lion's cage and see what you think of butchery then."
其他人则以更具创造力的方式想象我的死法。“你这只胆小鬼。我真想看你被关在狮子笼里，看看你到时候怎么想屠宰。”
The meat-eaters were just as impassioned. Here's a comment from my website. "People enjoy eating meat. Animals are made of meat. Therefore, we must eat the animals. Small woodland creatures, such as rabbits, rats, mice, et cetera, are just the chicken nuggets of the animal world anyway. And yes, I'll eat near any animal, long as you cook his ass up right."
肉食者们同样充满激情。这是我网站上的一条评论：“人们喜欢吃肉。动物就是肉做的。因此，我们必须吃动物。小型林地生物，比如兔子、老鼠、小鼠等，反正只是动物界的炸鸡块。是的，我会吃任何动物，只要你把他的屁股煮得恰到好处。”
While I found myself in the thick of this online fight, conducting media interviews and fielding death threats by phone, Chris and Levi were enduring visits to their homes by rather angry vegan activists. Levi took to sleeping with a gun under his pillow. While all this was happening, the rabbit advocacy group eventually returned, via their lawyer, all but one rabbit to Levi and Chris. The one rabbit that was not returned was a male breeder rabbit named Roger.
当我在网上战斗的漩涡中，进行媒体采访并应对电话里的死亡威胁时，克里斯和列维却在忍受着愤怒的纯素食激进分子的上门骚扰。列维开始在枕头下放一把枪睡觉。当这一切发生时，那个兔子权益组织最终通过律师，将除一只兔子以外的所有兔子都归还给了列维和克里斯。那只没有归还的兔子是一只名叫罗杰的雄性种兔。
Roger had been fostered to a woman who decided to hire her own lawyer. On January 12, 2012, just four days after the rabbit had gone missing, the lawyer sent a letter to us stating that the woman had grown attached to Roger and would like to offer $200, or the cost of replacing Roger, whichever was greater. In describing her client's feelings for Roger, which had developed over the course of four days, the lawyer also quoted Anatole France, a French poet, journalist, and novelist. "Until one has loved an animal, part of one's soul remains unawakened."
罗杰被寄养给了一位妇女，她决定聘请自己的律师。2012年1月12日，即兔子失踪仅四天后，律师发信给我们，声称该妇女已经对罗杰产生了感情，并愿意提供200美元或罗杰的重置成本，以较高者为准。在描述她的客户在四天内对罗杰产生的情感时，律师还引用了法国诗人、记者和小说家阿纳托尔·法郎士的话：“一个人除非爱过动物，否则他灵魂的一部分将保持未被唤醒的状态。”
Levi and Chris responded in the same manner as before. Return the rabbit, please. Then come talk to us, and we'll sell him to you at cost.
列维和克里斯以同样的方式做出了回应。请归还兔子，然后来找我们谈，我们会按成本价卖给你。
The woman did return Roger eventually. The hand-off occurred in her lawyer's office. She did not show up for the event. It was just Levi, the lawyer, and Roger, sitting alone together in a conference room. "Well, this is awkward," Levi said to the lawyer.
那名妇女最终确实归还了罗杰。交接是在她律师的办公室进行的。她没有露面。会议室里只有列维、律师和罗杰，他们独自坐在一起。“嗯，这很尴尬，”列维对律师说。
A few weeks later, Chris and Levi decided to sell the juvenile rabbits back to the rabbit advocacy group. I don't know the details of the sale, but the plan was to donate any profits to a Haitian charity that Levi works with a few times a year. Levi then received another letter from the lawyer representing Roger Rabbit's foster mother. Instead of simply knocking on Levi's door and offering $20 for Roger, the client offered to donate $1,000 to Levi's charity.
几周后，克里斯和列维决定把这些幼兔卖回给那个兔子权益组织。我不知道销售的细节，但计划是将任何利润捐给列维每年资助几次的一家海地慈善机构。列维随后又收到了一封代表罗杰兔子的寄养母亲的律师信。客户没有直接敲列维的门并提供20美元买下罗杰，而是提出向列维的慈善机构捐赠1000美元。
Levi accepted the offer. Roger was returned to his foster mother. Everyone was happy, especially the Haitians, who will benefit from a new program seeded by the $1,000 donation that teaches them how to raise rabbits-- for food.
列维接受了提议。罗杰被送还给了他的寄养母亲。每个人都很开心，尤其是海地人，他们将受益于由这1000美元捐款启动的一项新计划，该计划教他们如何饲养兔子——作为食物。
After all of this, it's my hunch that few if any minds were changed. People on all sides of the fight continued to do whatever it is they do. People who didn't eat meat continued to not eat it. People with bacon fetishes continued to wax poetic over pork belly. People who hate killing spiders continued to not kill spiders.
经过这一切，我的预感是几乎没有人改变想法。争论各方的人继续做着他们一直在做的事。不吃肉的人继续不吃肉。有培根癖好的人继续对猪腩诗意地赞美。讨厌杀死蜘蛛的人继续不杀蜘蛛。
Factory farms continued to cram thousands of cattle into confined spaces. Those who think of me as a sociopath continue to think of me that way. My classes continue to sell out.
工厂化农场继续将数千头牛塞进封闭的空间里。那些认为我是社会变态的人继续那样认为。我的课程继续售罄。
And yet I can't help but pay attention to the fact that all of us-- Levi, Chris, the people who stole the rabbits, the people who took them into their homes, and I-- all have something in common. All of us held the rabbits in our hands at some point, felt their pulse, contemplated their life, their deaths. Each of us tried to find meaning and make a stand within our very different acts. All of us thought we were doing the right thing.
然而，我无法不注意到一个事实：我们所有人——列维、克里斯、那些偷兔子的人、把兔子带回家的人，还有我——都有共同点。我们所有人都曾在某个时刻将兔子握在手中，感受过它们的心跳，思考过它们的生命和死亡。我们每个人都在自己非常不同的行为中寻找意义并表明立场。我们所有人都认为自己在做正确的事。
For those of us who choose to raise and kill animals for food, it's anything but a simple choice. In fact, it's hard and complicated every time. I look the animal in the eye as we breathe the same air. The same tree shades us. The world slows just long enough for us to see our shared place within it. And just before that moment that so few of us want to admit we're capable of-- that moment in which one animal chooses to kill another for food-- we're not only forced to realize what it means to be human, we're forced to realize what it means to be animal, too.
对于我们这些选择饲养和宰杀动物作为食物的人来说，这绝不是一个简单的选择。事实上，每一次都很艰难且复杂。当我们呼吸同样的空气时，我注视着动物的眼睛。同一棵树为我们遮荫。世界放慢了速度，足以让我们看到我们在其中的共享位置。就在那个我们很少人愿意承认自己有能力做出的时刻——那个动物选择杀害另一种动物作为食物的时刻——我们不仅被迫意识到作为人类意味着什么，我们也被迫意识到作为动物意味着什么。
Camas Davis in Portland, Oregon. A version of her essay first appeared in Oregon Humanities magazine.
波特兰俄勒冈州的卡马斯·戴维斯。她的文章版本首次出现在《俄勒冈人文》杂志上。
[MUSIC - "DEAD RABBIT" BY ROSE POLENZANI]
[音乐 - 罗斯·波伦扎尼的《死兔子》]
Act Three, Human Sacrifice. OK, this is a story that has been seven years in the making, though I did not realize that until very, very recently. In this story, it is not really the animal that is making the sacrifice, though you can be the judge of that. Here is Nancy Updike.
第三幕，人类牺牲。好吧，这是一个历时七年的故事，尽管直到最近我才意识到这一点。在这个故事中，实际上并不是动物在做出牺牲，尽管你可以自行判断。这是南希·厄普戴克。
There's a file in my brain labeled "Piney," P-I-N-E-Y, Piney. It's a slender file compared to lots of others. For instance, the one labeled "Ill-Considered Actions, 1987 Through Present." But the Piney file is intriguing exactly because it's so thin.
我的大脑里有一个标签为“派尼”（Piney，P-I-N-E-Y）的文件夹。与许多其他文件相比，它很薄。例如，那个标签为“考虑不周的行为，1987年至今”的文件。但派尼的文件正是因为单薄而耐人寻味。
What do you know about Piney?
你对派尼了解多少？
I don't know a lot about Piney.
我不太了解派尼。
What do you know about Piney?
你对派尼了解多少？
Piney's sort of this mysterious figure in our life.
派尼在我们生活中是个神秘人物。
I mean, my first impression was just Piney is misunderstood.
我的第一印象是派尼被误解了。
I would love to meet Piney's doctors. I've heard he has a team of doctors.
我很想见见派尼的医生。我听说他有一个医疗团队。
These people are all on staff at This American Life , and Piney is Ira's dog. The name comes from Ira's wife, Anaheed. She had a dream about having a dog named Piney. What else do people know?
这些人都是“美国生活”节目的员工，派尼是艾拉的狗。这个名字来自艾拉的妻子阿纳希德。她梦见自己有一只名叫派尼的狗。大家还知道些什么？
I know that Piney has to eat really specialized food.
我知道派尼必须吃非常特殊的食物。
We get boxes in the office, and those boxes are--
我们在办公室收到包裹，那些包裹是——
Kangaroo?
袋鼠肉？
Kangaroo, dry-ice-packed kangaroo meat. I know there've been others. I know there's been rabbits. Maybe there was bison, but I'm not sure.
袋鼠，干冰包装的袋鼠肉。我知道还有其他的。我知道有兔子。也许有野牛，但我不确定。
Yeah, there was bison.
是的，有野牛。
OK. I would like just a full list.
好吧。我只想要一份完整的清单。
I don't see it as extraordinary.
我不觉得这有什么非同寻常。
I don't understand how you don't see it as extraordinary. You're getting kangaroo meat delivered to our office in a radio studio.
我不明白你怎么会觉得这不特别。你居然把袋鼠肉送到我们在广播电台的办公室里。
All right, I agree at the point.
好吧，我同意这点。
Ira was the only person in the office who didn't see anything noteworthy about all this. I've known Ira for 17 years, and nothing he's ever done has raised more questions than Piney. It's not that he talks about Piney a lot. We're not a pet-crazed office. We don't have "bring your dog to work day."
艾拉是办公室里唯一觉得这一切没什么值得注意的人。我认识艾拉17年了，他做过的事情里没有一件比派尼引出的问题更多。并不是他经常谈论派尼。我们不是一个宠物狂热的办公室。我们没有“带狗上班日”。
But for years, we've been getting these snippets about Piney, sometimes double-take inducing. Piney takes Valium. Piney's eating ostrich now. Piney used to eat $90 worth of rabbits per week. Piney can't walk near men on the street, because if a man-- any man-- looks him in the eye, he'll attack him.
但多年来，我们一直听到关于派尼的零星片段，有时甚至让人怀疑人生。派尼在吃百忧解。派尼现在在吃鸵鸟肉。派尼过去每周要吃价值90美元的兔子。派尼不能在街上靠近男性，因为如果有男人——任何男人——看着他的眼睛，他就会攻击他。
The last time I saw Anaheed in the office, she was with Piney. And I went to give her a hug, and she said, "No, no, don't come over. Don't look at Piney." So we stood there chatting 10 feet apart.
最后一次在办公室见到阿纳希德时，她带着派尼。我想去给她一个拥抱，她说：“不，不，别过来。别看派尼。”所以我们站在那里，隔着10英尺聊天。
Until now, it's never quite felt OK to stop and say to Ira, can we talk about Piney?
直到现在，停下来对艾拉说“我们可以聊聊派尼吗？”似乎都不太合适。
Almost every person on staff I talked to about this, in almost every conversation, there was a moment when the person's voice dropped to a whisper, and they said, "Can I ask this? Is this OK?"
我谈论过这件事的每一位员工，几乎在每次谈话中，都会有一个时刻，对方的声音会压低到耳语程度，说：“我可以问吗？这样可以吗？”
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm surprised it didn't feel OK to ask.
我很惊讶问这个问题居然会让人觉得不合适。
To ask someone why are you-- I don't--
去问某人为什么你——我不——
Why are you throwing away your life?
为什么你要毁掉你的人生？
That's Ira's question. I wouldn't put it like that. Ira's pretty far from throwing his life away. But with his permission, I'm opening the Piney file.
那是艾拉的问题。我不会那样说。艾拉距离毁掉他的人生还很远。但在他的允许下，我打开了派尼的文件。
Piney's a smallish, sweet-faced pit bull. Think Little Rascals, not Michael Vick. He's a rescue, a very pretty dog, white with these big light-brown patches. He's timid. He can get scared of puppies and other animals much weaker than he is. But when he gets anxious, he sometimes attacks people.
派尼是一只小巧、甜美的比特犬。想象一下《小淘气》里的狗，而不是迈克尔·维克的狗。他是一只救援犬，非常漂亮，白色带大块浅棕色的斑点。他很胆小。他甚至会怕比他弱小得多的幼犬和其他动物。但当他焦虑时，他有时会攻击人。
He has to wear a muzzle whenever he goes anywhere outside Ira's apartment, including the office. Ira and his wife never have friends over, because Piney would go after them. Piney is fearful and anxiety prone. And he has to take Valium to keep from being even more aggressive.
无论艾拉带他去哪儿，包括办公室，他都必须戴上口套。艾拉和妻子从不邀请朋友来家里，因为派尼会去攻击他们。派尼胆小且易焦虑，他必须吃百忧解来防止变得更加狂躁。
It's almost like somebody who's fearful who is also a pit bull. If you imagine--
这几乎就像一个又胆小又是比特犬的家伙。如果你想象——
It's exactly that.
确实如此。
It is exactly that, yeah.
就是那样，是的。
It's not even like it. That is what is it.
甚至不需要“像”。他就是那样的。
That is what it is. He was a normal dog until a wedding that Anaheed took him to. Anaheed drove up ahead of me, and the dog was there with her and was a puppy. And all these people were hanging around.
他就是那样的。他本来是一只正常的狗，直到阿纳希德带他去参加了一场婚礼。阿纳希德比我先开车到，狗和她在一起，当时还是只小狗。周围全是人。
And there was a moment where he bit the host's daughter, Hope, who was 9 or 10 at the time. He just got up off the floor, saw her come into the room, walked over, and bit her. And then he bit a friend of ours, Vicky, her son.
当时他咬了主人的女儿霍普，当时她9或10岁。他只是从地板上站起来，看到她进屋，走过去咬了她。然后他又咬了我们朋友维基的儿子。
At the wedding, he bit two children?
在婚礼上，他咬了两个孩子？
He bit two children.
他咬了两个孩子。
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
So we took him home. And that's what put us on notice of, oh, right.
所以我们把他带回家了。那件事让我们警觉起来，哦，是的。
Piney had already been trained at that point to obey commands, to sit, to pee outside. But he hadn't gotten training especially for aggressive dogs, because they hadn't known he was aggressive. So that's what came next. Mixed results.
派尼在那时已经受过指令训练，坐下、在外面撒尿。但他没有接受过针对攻击性犬只的专门训练，因为他们之前不知道他有攻击性。所以接下来发生的就是这个。结果好坏参半。
One, two, three, four, five.
一，二，三，四，五。
What are you counting?
你在数什么？
One, two, three, four, five, six--
一，二，三，四，五，六——
You're counting people the dog has bitten. I can see where you're counting on your list.
你在数那只狗咬过的人。我看到你在你的名单上数数。
Yeah, it's six plus Anaheed.
是的，再加上阿纳希德，有六个人。
He's bitten Anaheed?
他咬过阿纳希德？
A couple times. It might be more than twice, actually.
好几次。实际上可能不止两次。
More than twice.
不止两次。
Yeah, a bunch of times. He nips each time. Each time it's a nip, but it does draw blood.
是的，很多次。每次他都是轻轻咬一下。每次都是轻轻一咬，但确实会出血。
I don't know if you're allowed to call it a nip if it draws blood.
我不知道出血了还能不能叫“轻轻一咬”。
No, nip includes drawing blood.
不，轻轻一咬也包括出血。
No, bite includes drawing blood. Nip is not breaking the skin.
不，咬才包括出血。轻轻一咬是不破皮的。
What if we call it a bloody nip?
如果我们叫它“带血的轻咬”呢？
Then we'd have to be in England. We would have to be in a London pub.
那我们就得在英国了。我们得在伦敦的酒吧里。
He gave her a bloody nip.
他给了她一下带血的轻咬。
Ira told me I should think of Piney like the Incredible Hulk-- fundamentally good, just high-strung. But my understanding of the Hulk is that he only blew up for a very important reasons that were worth building a movie or TV series or comic book around. Piney goes Hulk during ordinary life circumstances. For instance, he feels he has to protect Anaheed from Ira in situations like she's asleep and Ira's awake.
艾拉告诉我应该把派尼想象成绿巨人——本质上是好的，只是容易紧张。但我对绿巨人的理解是，他只因为值得拍摄电影、电视剧或漫画的非常重要的原因才爆发。派尼在日常生活中也会绿巨人化。例如，他觉得有必要在某些情况下保护阿纳希德不受艾拉伤害，比如她睡着了而艾拉醒着。
That's a daily occurrence.
那是每天都会发生的事。
And what does he do to protect her?
他怎么保护她？
He'll lunge at me as if to attack me. Including this morning, like many mornings, he woke me up at 5:30 in the morning to go out and pee. So I get up, and I put on clothes. And it's cold.
他会像攻击一样扑向我。包括今天早上，像很多个早上一样，他在凌晨5点半把我叫醒出去尿尿。所以我起床，穿上衣服。外面很冷。
And I put on his leash and his muzzle, and find some plastic bags, and find my keys, and put on shoes, and go down five flights, and take him out. And he pees. And then I know as soon as we walk back into the apartment, because she's asleep, he'll then turn and try to kill me, or make a show of aggression. And I always feel like, dude, remember who's your friend.
我给他系上牵引绳和口套，找几个塑料袋，拿上钥匙，穿上鞋子，下五层楼，带他出去。他尿尿了。然后我知道只要我们一走回公寓，因为她在睡觉，他就会转过身试图杀了我，或者表现出攻击性。我总是觉得，老兄，记住谁才是你的朋友。
We were just peeing together.
我们刚才还一起尿尿来着。
We were just peeing. Remember? You needed some help. I helped you out. Remember, we're buddies? And he really can't help it.
我们刚才还尿过。记得吗？你需要帮助。我帮你解脱了。记得吗，我们是伙伴？他真的控制不住自己。
And then I was just like, generally, all I have to do is say, hey, Piney, where's your toy? And  he thinks, oh, a toy.
然后我就说，一般情况下，我只要说，“嘿，派尼，你的玩具在哪里？”他就会想，哦，玩具。
Meaning, let me stop attacking Ira right now and play with this ball.
意思是，让我现在停止攻击艾拉，去玩这个球。
Exactly. So if I just have something that he can tug on with if he's acting aggressively, he'll just take it out on the tugging. When I look in his eyes, in those moments, his eyes are not the "I want to kill you" sort of eyes of a creature that's trying to hurt you. His eyes are in the kind of "I can't control myself, please, I feel trapped inside this situation."
完全正确。所以如果在他表现出攻击性时我有样东西能让他去啃咬，他就会把火气撒在啃咬上。当我在那些时刻看着他的眼睛，他的眼神不像那种想伤害你的生物的“我想杀了你”的眼神。他的眼神是那种“我无法控制自己，拜托，我觉得被困在这个情境里了”。
It's funny. I've never thought about how it sounds to you guys, that it sounds like, oh. It sounds dangerous, is what you're saying.
有趣的是。我从未想过这对你们来说听起来是什么样的，它听起来像，哦。它是危险的，这就是你们要说的。
Yeah. You can't have people come to your apartment. No one, no friend, nobody you work with, no one has ever seen the inside of your apartment, right?
是的。你不能让任何人来你的公寓。没有朋友，没有同事，从来没有人见过你们公寓的内部，对吧？
Correct. Yeah, because he would attack anybody who came in. And then we tried to train it out of him. We had trainers come over to the apartment to do exercises to train that out of him. But those were not successful.
正确。是的，因为他会攻击任何进来的人。然后我们试着通过训练改掉这个毛病。我们请训练师到公寓里做练习来改掉这个毛病。但都不成功。
And how big a deal is that?
这有多严重？
To me, that's a huge big deal. Because for me, I feel like, well, let's just put him in daycare overnight and have a dinner party. But Anaheed's not so into that. So for me, that's huge. I'd like to live an adult life where we could have people over.
对我来说，这非常严重。因为对我来说，我觉得，嗯，我们把他放在日托中心过夜，开个晚宴吧。但阿纳希德不太喜欢那样。所以对我来说，这很严重。我想过一种成年人的生活，能邀请人过来。
There definitely have been points where we both had a lot of despair about were we going to be able to get him to a point where it was livable comfortably. Yeah, we definitely had moments where we both felt like, oh, this feels sort of hopeless.
肯定有那么几个时刻，我们都对他能否达到一个舒适的生活点感到绝望。是的，我们肯定有过那样的时刻，感觉，哦，这感觉有点绝望。
Piney shapes Ira's life. Ira has less free time than anyone I know. And for the last seven years, he's been spending most of it on Piney. I'm sure that's true for Anaheed, too. Piney's behavioral problems, the time and expense of training and medicine, avoiding situations that could set him off-- all of that is only part of it.
派尼塑造了艾拉的生活。艾拉拥有的空闲时间比我认识的任何人都少。在过去的七年里，他把大部分时间都花在了派尼身上。我相信阿纳希德也是一样。派尼的行为问题、训练和医药的时间和金钱成本、避免可能触发他的情境——这一切只是其中一部分。
Piney also developed, as a young dog, severe allergies and an autoimmune disease that almost killed him twice. He's got four doctors. And one of them said to put him on a simple diet-- one starch, one protein, the same starch and protein every day. So Ira and Anaheed started cooking for Piney.
派尼还在幼年时就患上了严重的过敏症和一种两次差点杀死他的自身免疫性疾病。他有四位医生。其中一位说让他进行简单的饮食——一种淀粉，一种蛋白质，每天同样的淀粉和蛋白质。所以艾拉和阿纳希德开始为派尼做饭。
Is this more time than you're spending on cooking for yourselves, just as a comparison?
这比你们自己做饭花的时间多吗，作为一个比较？
Yes, completely. Yeah, totally. Yeah, most of the cooking in our house is cooking for the dog.
是的，完全多。是的，完全是。大多数家里的烹饪都是为狗做的。
The cooking plan has worked. Piney's pretty much OK when he eats this way. But then he always develops a new allergy to whatever he's been eating. And then he's got to switch, from all bison to all pork, to all rabbit, to all tuna, to venison, to ostrich.
烹饪计划奏效了。派尼这样吃的时候基本没事。但随后他总是会对吃的东西产生新的过敏。然后他必须更换，从全野牛肉，到全猪肉，全兔肉，全金枪鱼，再到鹿肉，鸵鸟肉。
Kangaroo was hard, because you can't really buy kangaroo many places. And there was a butcher that we could go to, but it was like an hour's ride on the subway away. And so once every couple weeks, I would get on the subway and ride for an hour and go to this one butcher.
袋鼠肉很难，因为你没法在很多地方买到袋鼠肉。有一个我们可以去的屠夫，但那得坐一个小时的地铁。所以每隔几周，我就得坐上地铁，坐一个小时，去找这个屠夫。
Sometimes the meat was delivered here. But you're saying sometimes you would go and get it. It wasn't flown in.
有时肉会送到这里。但你是说有时你会亲自去拿。它不是空运来的。
There were two different kinds of kangaroo. One were these prepackaged veterinary-- there are veterinary services where they'll make up the meals for you. So since it's a starch and a meat, you can get them made kangaroo and then a starch. But in order to give him his pills, which he takes many of, and to give him treats, you would also need just pieces of kangaroo. And for that, I would go on the train ride to get the kangaroo.
袋鼠肉有两种。一种是预包装的兽医产品——有一些兽医服务会为你配制膳食。因为这是一种淀粉加一种肉，你可以买到配好的袋鼠肉和淀粉。但为了给他吃他服用的那些药丸，以及作为奖励，你还需要单独的袋鼠肉块。为此，我会坐火车去拿。
On the hour-long train ride out to get the kangaroo, and the hour-long train ride back, do you remember that ever being an occasion for--
在那一小时去拿袋鼠肉的火车旅程中，和一小时回来的旅程中，你记得那曾经是一个——
Yes. Resentment? Yes.
是的。怨恨？是的。
Resentment, questioning-- what would you think about?
怨恨，质问——你会想什么？
If I was in a resentful kind of mood, resentment over that would snowball with all the other resentments that I'm feeling. It masses quickly.
如果我处于一种怨恨的情绪中，对那件事的怨恨会像雪球一样，随着我感受到的所有其他怨恨滚在一起。它积压得很快。
Each week we have a theme, and all of our resentments will be a different kind of resentment on that theme.
每周我们都有一个主题，我们所有的怨恨都会是那个主题下的不同怨恨。
Exactly, yeah. And then sometimes I would be coming back from-- I would have a public-radio event in some other city. So I would leave early Saturday and go and do a speech and then come back at the crack of dawn on Sunday morning, fly home, and then on the way back from the airport, have them drop me off at the butcher, where I would pick up the kangaroo and then take my suitcase and the meat and get on the train and drive an hour.
完全正确。有时我会从——我会去其他城市参加公共广播活动。所以我周六一大早出发，演讲，然后在周日凌晨赶回来，飞回家，然后在从机场回来的路上，让他们把我放在屠夫那里，我会带上行李箱和肉，乘火车开一个小时。
And it's hard not to feel a little sorry for yourself in that situation, and a little mad about having a dog. And you don't feel good about the dog in those moments. Or I didn't feel good about having a dog, many, many times.
在那样的处境下很难不为自己感到难过，对养狗感到有点生气。在那些时刻你感觉不到养狗的好处。或者我多次多次没有感受到养狗的好处。
And I understand if people roll their eyes at everything that we're doing. If I were to hear of somebody doing what we're doing, I would be the first to roll my eyes. If I hear about people cooking for their dog-- oh my god, what could be more repulsive? People cooking for their dog. That's ridiculous.
如果人们对我们所做的一切翻白眼，我完全理解。如果我听说有人在做我们正在做的事，我会是第一个翻白眼的人。如果我听说人们为他们的狗做饭——哦我的天啊，还有什么比这更让人反感的吗？人们为他们的狗做饭。那太荒谬了。
And how does that coexist in your brain with cooking for your dog every day?
在你大脑里，这和你每天为你的狗做饭是怎么并存的？
Well, I don't have a problem thinking that something I do is laughable or ridiculous. You don't want to be that person, but then you are that person.
嗯，我不觉得承认自己做的事很可笑或荒谬有什么问题。你不想成为那样的人，但结果你就是那样的人。
I was on Reddit answering questions. And somebody asked about the dog and about what is the dog eating. And I listed all the different foods. And then I said, the logical end of this is that eventually, the only thing left would be human flesh, and Anaheed and I would have to feed ourselves to the dog. That's the obvious place where the whole thing goes.
我在Reddit上回答问题。有人问起这只狗，问它在吃什么。我列出了所有不同的食物。然后我说，这逻辑上的终点是，最终剩下的唯一东西就是人肉了，阿纳希德和我将不得不把自己喂给狗。这就是整件事显然的走向。
Do you ever feel like that's already happening?
你是否有时觉得那正在发生？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Just in terms of--
只是从——
Yes, I do.
是的，我是。
Time, and effort, and--
时间和精力，还有——
I absolutely do. Yeah, of course. Yeah.
我绝对是。是的，当然。
Have you discussed what a limit would be?
你们讨论过极限在哪里吗？
No. I have fantasies about him not existing.
没有。我幻想过他不存在。
Like what?
比如什么？
Just that our lives would be so much easier and nicer.
只是觉得我们的生活会轻松愉快得多。
Does he bring something to your life? Is there a good part? Is there pleasure?
他给你的生活带来了什么？有好的部分吗？有快乐吗？
Yeah, of course. It's not as much pleasure as the amount of work it is. All the pleasures are really corny ones. Like it's really sweet to have this animal that trusts no one and is alone in this world except for us. And he trusts us.
是的，当然。这并没有像工作量那么大的快乐。所有的快乐都是非常老套的。比如，拥有这只不信任任何人、在这个世界上除了我们之外一无所有的动物，这真的很甜蜜。他信任我们。
And he's a nervous dog. And to get him out of his head, and he's just running after a ball, and he's bringing it back. And you throw it again, over and over, and he's super happy, like a normal dog-- it's really sweet to see. It really feels like a triumph.
他是一只神经质的狗。让他从思维中跳出来，他在追球，他把它带回来。你一次又一次地扔，他超级开心，就像一只正常的狗——看到这个真的很甜蜜。这感觉真的像是一场胜利。
And he's sweet, as a dog. I love him. And I love my wife. And it would kill her if we could've kept him alive longer and we didn't do it. And that was true so early on that any other premise was unthinkable.
他很甜，作为一只狗。我爱他。我爱我的妻子。如果我们能让他活得更久而没这样做，她会崩溃的。这在很早之前就是事实，以至于任何其他前提都是不可想象的。
That's why it's not a question. That's why you can say all this stuff. And I feel like if you picture a little scale with a balance, it's not even weighing anything on that side of it.
这就是为什么这不是一个问题。这就是为什么你可以说所有这些话。我觉得如果你想象一个带平衡的小秤，它在那一侧甚至没有权衡任何东西。
Well, because it's not about the dog. The thing on the other side of the scale is Anaheed, not the dog. I think that's what's hard to understand from the outside is that it seems like, ah, it's about this dog. But it's about your relationship with your wife.
嗯，因为这不是关于狗。秤另一边的东西是阿纳希德，不是狗。我认为这就是从外部难以理解的地方，看起来好像，啊，这是关于这只狗。但这是关于你和你妻子的关系。
But the thing is if Anaheed were to just vanish off the face of the earth, I would still take care of the dog. Years ago, she made me promise that if she were to suddenly die, I would keep the dog alive. And at that point, it was kind of like a 50/50 choice, and I said I would as a promise to her. But now it doesn't matter that I promised her. I would just do it.
但关键是，如果阿纳希德从地球上消失了，我还是会照顾这只狗。几年前，她让我承诺，如果她突然去世，我会让这只狗活下去。那时候这就像一个50/50的选择，我答应她是因为承诺。但现在我是否向她承诺已经不重要了。我就是会这样做。
And what changed?
是什么改变了？
It's a hard thing to spend so much energy trying to protect a helpless creature, or a helpless person, or anything that's helpless. It's a hard thing to turn that off. Once you've been protecting it, your mind is used to protecting it. And the thought that you wouldn't protect it just becomes offensive to who you are. You can't flip off that part of yourself like it's a light switch.
花这么多精力试图保护一个无助的生物、一个无助的人，或任何无助的东西，是一件很难的事情。一旦你开始保护它，很难关闭这个开关。一旦你一直在保护它，你的思维习惯了去保护它。而你不去保护它的想法反而成为了对你自我的冒犯。你不能像开关电灯一样关闭那部分的自己。
It's interesting that you consider him helpless, though, since he lunges at you every day. And you see helplessness behind I think what other people see as aggression.
有趣的是，虽然你认为他无助，因为他每天都向你扑过来。而我认为你看到了别人眼中攻击性背后的无助。
Now I see that. Right, but fundamentally in this world, he's 1 foot tall. He weighs 60 pounds. He can't earn any money. He doesn't speak the English language.
现在我看到了。对，但从根本上在这个世界上，他只有1英尺高。他重60磅。他赚不到钱。他不会说英语。
I'm in charge. You know what I mean? Like I could have him killed any day.
我是负责人。你懂我的意思吗？我可以随时让人把他杀了。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program, doing the easiest slash most delicate interview she's ever done for the show.
南希·厄普戴克是我们节目的制作人之一，完成了她为节目所做过最简单也是最微妙的采访。
What are you thinking as you're making that face? What is that face?
你在做那个表情时在想什么？那是说明表情？
I'm alarmed that you seem to be, just after all this talk, that you don't seem at all convinced that what we're doing doesn't seem nuts. Do you know what I mean? I could understand how it would seem that way before you heard me explain it. But now that I've explained it, I feel like you should come over to my side. And I can't believe that you haven't.
我很震惊，你似乎，在经过所有这些谈话后，看起来完全不相信我们所做的事情并不疯狂。你明白我的意思吗？在听到我解释之前，我能理解为什么它看起来那样。但现在我已经解释过了，我觉得你应该站在我这一边。我简直不敢相信你还没有。
You're saying you did everything right, so how could I be doing this so wrong.
你在说你做的一切都是对的，所以我怎么可能做错了。
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[笑] 是的。
Yeah.
是的。
[MUSIC - "NEVER GONNA GIVE YOU UP" BY JERRY  BUTLER]
[音乐 - 杰里·巴特勒的《绝不放弃你》]
Well, today's program was produced by Robyn Semien, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from Tarek Fouda. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
好吧，今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩制作，参与者有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·科尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普戴克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自塔雷克·福达。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。音乐协助来自达米恩·格雷夫和罗伯·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who just got the results from his annual psych evaluation.
“美国生活”节目由公共广播国际公司发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他刚刚收到了年度心理评估结果。
Those who think of me as a sociopath continue to think of me that way.
那些认为我是社会变态的人继续那样认为。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再带着更多“美国生活”的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。